[Music]
nurses have been on the front lines of
the pandemic since the very beginning
we're working in a state of very high
stress
the psychological tension has gone
through the roof
many paid for their service with their
lives
the world health organization estimates
that 115
000 nurses worldwide have died in
connection with a coronavirus infection
is the nurse's hard work being given the
appreciation it deserves
many are still waiting for the financial
applause
[Applause]
and they are demanding better working
conditions
how can it be that the heroes of the
pandemic are still struggling
for recognition welcome to your covet 19
special i'm chris coburn berlin
despite their heroic efforts healthcare
workers around the world are now
learning
that they are subject to a rather
unforgiving system
take spain where more than 80 doctors
and nurses themselves
fell victim to the coronavirus the
government promised
to improve working conditions but
instead with infection rates declining
thousands of healthcare workers have
already been laid off
or soon will be dw's young philip
schultz reports from valencia
in eastern spain laura
almodever has been told her services are
no longer required here on the kovid 19
ward but she still has her hands full
many of her colleagues at the valencia
clinic
are gone in the surrounding region alone
hundreds of nurses were let go overnight
many of her co-workers were informed
that they'd been laid off
in a text message
i think it's shocking to find out your
employment has been terminated like this
it shows zero respect for the people who
gave everything during the pandemic
a standing ovation for health workers
the heroes of the pandemic
when spain was particularly hard hit by
coronavirus in march 2020
thousands of nurses were hired at short
notice many
fell ill some even died of the virus
but now the covid19 19 numbers are
falling across the country
these nurses are no longer needed more
than 1 000
nurses have been laid off here in the
valencia region in the past few weeks
alone
for thousands more their professional
future is uncertain
within a few months they seem to have
gone from heroes of the pandemic
to redundant personnel the layoffs have
led to furious protests here
most of those who have been sacked are
afraid to speak to us
on camera only one person is willing to
speak anonymously
by telephone he tells us that he and his
colleagues feel abandoned
when the virus happened we were short of
everything we needed to fight it
we were brutally overloaded with work we
couldn't even take care of our own
health
and that had extreme effects on our
private and family life
now it all seems like exploitation to me
in recent years spain has made massive
cuts to its public health system
more than a third of medical staff only
have short-term contracts
and many clinics have been privatized
during the pandemic the government
promised improvements
but instead the situation has worsened
and yet those in charge
haven't changed their tune
we are currently making great efforts to
create more permanent positions and to
ensure that fewer people have to work in
unsafe conditions
we hope that the situation will improve
in 2022.
for nurse laura almodever and her fired
colleagues
there could be some good news at least
for now
many of them will be reinstated over the
summer to fill in for others
who've gone on vacation
let's get more on this with howard
catton he's the ceo of the international
council of nurses icn and he joins me
from geneva in switzerland welcome back
to our show howard
zero respect for the people who gave
everything during the pandemic as one
nurse called the sacking of healthcare
workers in the report we just seen
do you agree i think this is a
shameful way to treat nurses and health
care workers
these are the people who have put
themselves ahead of everybody
else who've gone to work knowing that
there's a greater
risk that they might become infected
haven't had the personal protective
equipment that they need
have often separated themselves from
their family so as not to present a risk
to them who have stepped into the shoes
of
relatives they are not disposable
they are indispensable they are the
heart of our
health care systems and we're seeing
around the world
uh nurses who are angry at this
lack of recognition and respect and an
increase in strikes in europe in
africa and in the pacific region as well
on that note um
healthcare workers do have a huge
leverage particularly now on the
pandemic
if protests grew if more nurses went on
strike
that would create enormous pressure for
their cause wouldn't it
we went into this pandemic six million
nurses
short globally we've got aging nursing
workforce in many
countries we've got nurses who have left
because of
burnout because of anxiety we don't know
the impact of long coved the last thing
we can afford to do
is to lose our nurses our hospitals our
clinics
without staff without nurses they're
just empty buildings it's the people
that matter
and we should be investing and in them
and protecting them
now the pandemic is at a different stage
in different parts of the world
do you see situations improving for
healthcare workers in areas
with high infection rates because of the
lessons learned
earlier elsewhere
we are seeing many places where
nurses are taking on increasing
leadership positions they're at the
forefront of the public health messages
organizing systems of care as as well
and the situation is improving but
we are also seeing areas where uh the
virus is resurgent and there is a huge
issue at the moment
with the inequity of access to vaccines
for nurses and healthcare workers there
are nurses and health workers in some
parts of the world
still waiting to be vaccinated whilst
younger people are being jabbed in other
countries we all know we're not going to
win this
race against the virus on our own as
nations it is a global race and we need
to see
much more sharing and solidarity and
cooperation around the world
in an icn report published earlier this
year it says uh
studies across regions suggest that the
pandemic
has exacerbated the stress and anxiety
felt by nurses and other health care
workers what do these people suffer from
in particular
we have seen huge physical and
psychological impacts
on nursing and healthcare staff physical
exhaustion insomnia
burnout and stress but also
the emotional burden of being away from
your family
looking after people more people who are
seriously ill
who are fearful more people who are
dying
on top of that we have also seen
examples of
discrimination and violence against
nurses
people who may be ignorant or fearful
but you know nurses who've not been able
to renew their tenancy because their
landlord is worried that they're
spreading the virus nurses having
difficulty accessing
child care for their children as well
and nurses being subject to
the kovid deniers who are saying this
whole thing is a hoax
we we've called this a mass
traumatization of the nursing workforce
and that's why we need to be
focusing on the recovery of our nurses
in our healthcare
workforce right now howard catton of the
international council of nurses
thank you for your thoughts thank you
getting the right jab has for many
people been the most promising
way to protect themselves against a
severe coronavirus infection
vaccines have been subject of many of
your questions
here's one and our science correspondent
derek williams
every country has a different strategy
to prioritize vaccines
what does the science say about how to
best allocate them
we're still in the middle of the biggest
vaccine drive
in history so evaluating the moving data
on this topic
is really a pretty tall order to be
honest
i don't even know if looking back in the
years to come
if we'll be able to say anything with
certainty
about whether countries might have
prioritized
the right groups for vaccine allocation
in the right order that's because
demographics are so different in
different countries that
that making blanket statements about
what works best
can i think provide at best just
rough guidelines there are just too many
variables
the big problem is that allocating
vaccines means
making choices that are at odds with
each other
the most obvious of those choices is is
whether to cut
down on the death and suffering caused
by the disease
as quickly as possible by vaccinating
the most vulnerable first
or to instead try to vaccinate those
who are most exposed so so those who
will catch the disease most often
and hence really drive further
transmission
countries with aging populations like
many
here in europe went for the first option
they decided to
prioritize the elderly the group that's
most at risk
if they contract covet 19 and and that
choice seems to be working at preventing
death and suffering um a british health
care authority for instance
has estimated that the campaign there
which focused on getting elderly the
shots first
that it saved over 30 000
hospitalizations
and and 10 000 lives so far
but that's also left a large segment of
the population
younger people um unvaccinated for
for many months and of course as the
group
that's most regularly exposed they're
now fueling
a new outbreak there so what's the best
prioritization strategy i don't really
know if you can put it that way i'd say
that there are just strategies
with different outcomes